all right people the debate number two
it just ended they are did they shake
hands
I missed it did anyone see if they shook
hands no we don't know if they shook
hands they didn't shake hands at the
beginning which was extremely tense so
there's obviously a lot to talk about
first of all I want to know what you
guys are drinking we're going beer here
tonight I was I was beer last time did
some wine there might have been some
vodka
last time tequila here and there but I
want to know what you guys are drinking
what's the drink of choice what was the
drinking game that people do for these
things so there's a lot to talk about
here I would highly recommend for those
of you watching right now to tell your
friends to watch this or something like
this rather than watching CNN or MSNBC
or Fox News or the network coverage
where they're just gonna put on campaign
Sarah it's right now and guess what
you're not gonna believe this guys I'm
an insider I know this kind of stuff the
the Hillary people the Hillary
supporters are people they like Hillary
the people that used to work for Hillary
but now we're networks they're gonna say
Hillary won and the people that work for
Trump or that used to work for Trump or
that are on the networks is the Trump
surrogates they're all gonna say the
Trump woman I just trust him you've got
to trust me on this I just have a strong
feeling about it and I've been right
every time it's incredible anyway so you
guys can I've got the team here the
Rubin report team we've got three people
in a dog
we are monitoring computers there's
several computers here there's an iPad
than iPhones all kinds of things so you
can you can ask me questions in the
comment section right down below or you
can tweet at me because I know the
comments here on the YouTube get a
little nutty especially after a debate
when people have been drinking although
I did see right before I jumped in here
alive but somebody said well the Rubin
Report comment section is not a [ __ ]
show that's really the nicest thing that
you can say about a comment section okay
so let's start with that with the
obvious stuff the first 20 minutes and
of course everything that's led us up to
this in the last 24 hours so you know
the tape of Trump and and Billy Bush
came out he said some gross stuff it's
just gross stuff guys say that kind of
stuff it's hard you know there's a
difference between words and actions so
these are just words just things the
guys say behind closed doors or that
girls say or that gay dudes say or
whoever says is
difference between just saying [ __ ]
privately and and when your actions
actually are so this is on [ __ ] that he
said it was pretty gross actually the
stuff that he was saying although I
think one of the things that really got
glossed over in this whole thing I don't
really know the work of Billy Bush he's
not in my wheelhouse although I think
it's kind of funny that I made Billy
Bush is taken down by [ __ ] but um oh
right then I want me to say [ __ ] as
much anymore
no more [ __ ] here we go so but the
thing that was interesting was so they
have this whole you know conversation in
the in the bus and then they meet the
woman outside and after all of that
Billy Bush says to the woman why don't
you hug it which that seemed actually
more gross and offensive than the things
that Trump said which actually works a
the point is that what you do what you
say privately and I would say this for
anyone any of us saying the privacy of
our own home and by the way I think it's
actually kind of funny that all of these
people all of these pundits and all
these TV people that have you know they
have mics on them all the time and I
know what that's like
I've been on things on on online mostly
but I've even been on television things
where people's hot mics have been left
on and you know you just forget things
go to commercial breaks and you could
say [ __ ] now I'm like I'm not defending
any of the things that people say but
I'm sure that I have said things I'm not
talking about racist things or something
like that but I'm sure I've said things
that I wouldn't want other people to
know I can actually think of an instance
a hundred percent
I was once when I was working at TYT
they they left the mic on during the
break and I started talking [ __ ] about
some guy I was in high school it was
this right kind of bully guy whatever
that I didn't like and how I saw him at
my reunion he was a loser and I was so
happy about it I'm talking [ __ ] about
his family and I said his name I'm gonna
saw people tweeting at me that my mic
was on so [ __ ] like that happens and
what you say I believe is not
necessarily what you would say publicly
that doesn't excuse it but there's a
difference between just words and
actions so that's number one so anyway
so also the beginning of the debate the
first twenty minutes now of course you
guys all know that Trump had the four
women there and you know one thing that
I think is really interesting about the
four women look I don't know and I don't
think you know what Bill Clinton
or do we we live in a time when people
are accused of rape all the time it
lives are destroyed and whether it was
sexual assault or rape or whatever you
want to call it although he was a man of
incredible power which complicates what
I think the definition of great might be
but the point is that these women have
been pretty much ignored and mocked and
forgotten about and I was shocked he was
actually kind of disgusting to see the
way people were kind of dismissing them
all day long people on the left on the
media were just dismissing them now I
get it
Trump is using them for his own purposes
without question without question he's
doing that and just the fact that we
were all focused on rape and sexual
assault before a presidential debate and
that they're there this isn't how it's
supposed to be you know this is this is
not really we'll get into some of the
ideas that they talk about over the
course of the hour and a half but this
isn't it we're supposed to having a real
debate about ideas that's what this
really should be about and unfortunately
it really isn't it's become that all
sighs so anyway so I see some questions
rolling in so I just do lumore recap at
the beginning thing that'll stop the
questions and then jump ahead so what I
would say is the first 20 minutes were
incredibly they were hostile and it felt
weird didn't you feel like I actually
kind of felt weird like in my heart felt
weird and I think most people think that
there was this feeling in over the way
they were kind of walking around each
other and you knew how much tension was
there and Bill Clinton was sitting up
there and the women were there and all
of this stuff and it's like at the same
time Trump was clearly trying to be
controlled and somewhat apologetic I
don't think any of it comes off as
particularly sincere but you know the
first 20 minutes like he was it was sort
of like whoa where is this thing gonna
go like is this gonna eat up the whole
thing but then it ended up not and they
got into some substantive stuff the
moderators I'd say you know generally I
would be for not having moderators and
let them actually debate you know every
time a moderator jumps in and says oh
don't interrupt him you've been
interrupted when he interrupted you it's
like we need a debate not a canned
question and an answer in a response you
need to debate ideas these things google
the word debate these things are not
this was
all but these things are not really
debates we need to have them battling
the ideas while looking at each other
while looking at each other not just
talking to somebody else off there that
would be much harder to do so anyway so
in terms of just one loss and then I'll
get some questions so everyone was who
won who lost through the Twitter polls
in a win and a loss the truth of the win
and the loss is only if someone changed
their mind
because of this whether you think Trump
did better or you think Hillary did
better it is irrelevant unless a certain
amount of people change their minds
during the course of this I think all
Trump basically had to do the bar was so
low because of everything that's
happened last couple days is that he
just didn't have to implode and he
didn't implode I think I think he had a
couple nice moments which I'll get to in
a little bit
he didn't implode and she didn't she
didn't make him implode Oh Hillary what
she had to do was keep going you know
it's just she has a state of course and
not just Doral for some for some crazy
reason but Trump did implode and that's
pretty much all he had to do to keep
this thing marching marching down the
road over 30 days out so let me jump on
a couple questions and then we'll go
from there
let's see Dave what do you think about
taxation on the world so people have
asked me about this at lunch and I've
talked about it a little bit more and I
absolutely will get some more economist
on the show my general rule is that
people should have lower taxes so you
have more money in your pockets so that
you can make the choices with your money
with what you want to do with it even
the look at the government always has
money for war they never run out of
money for bombs so it's not that they
need more money I would like a slimmer
trimmer go and you should be able to
spend your money as you see fit so we
have to uncomplicate the tax code I saw
I saw this morning I think our tax laws
something like 3.8 million words do you
think anyone has really read this thing
so some guy somehow got all figured out
to council words I haven't read but
something in like Germany and France I
think they said they have less than 10%
of the word it's not that it's about the
worry captain birthday but but so we
have to simplify it so I would be for
something that would be like you don't
a and again I'm not an economist but I
would be for something along these lines
basically if you make under fifty
thousand dollars you don't have to pay
tax it's just whoo let's let you save
your money properly so you can try to
get ahead or whatever then above that I
would do a flat tax basically for like
for pretty much everybody until say ten
million dollars and you put it like 15
percent or something but you figure out
what the right percentage is and then
until you make ten million dollars
anyone from 50 to ten million that's
pretty much everybody
it pays 15 percent and then above ten
yeah maybe you notch that up to 20 and
then above say 50 million you pay 25
percent something like that so yes if
you're at the tip at the top you can pay
more into the system and and you know
the people at the top do pay most of the
taxes right now and they get most of the
benefits of that of course so I would be
for something that protects the people
at the bottom so you don't have to pay
taxes if you're making under 50 and I
had many many many years of my life for
four more years than I'd like to admit
that I was making less than fifty you
don't you don't have to pay taxes and
and then above that you figure out some
flat tax with a little bit of a scale on
it to weigh out when people are making
beccamike that's what that's what I
would if you guys want to yell out like
particularly good ones go ahead okay so
yeah okay oh this is interesting to
debates and zero global warming
questions we passed 400 p.m. carbon this
year so it's we're basically at the
point of no return why is this being
discussed of course we should be
discussing this and this is a damn shame
we're wasting so much time on nonsense
and this is when I talk about the battle
of ideas this is what I'm talking about
that we have to have honest
conversations about these things and you
guys know on my show I have had Michael
Mann who you know who's one of the
leading climate scientists in the entire
world from Penn State University who
wrote who came up with a hockey stick
theory that basically we're getting to
the point where our explosion of global
warming is gonna be so fast because of
the the combination of what we're
putting out there and what's there and
the greenhouse effect and all that and
then I've also had Alex Epstein on who
wrote a book called the moral case for
fossil fuels who basically claims that
that climate change is a hoax and all
that I try
talk to both people on both sides on
this I got a ton of [ __ ] a ton of [ __ ]
maybe more [ __ ] than I've ever gotten
for anything even more than talking to
Milo by talking to Alex Epstein and they
absolutely should be talking about this
you know it's it's whether you want to
believe it or not I'm not a scientist so
as I said to Alex Epps that on the show
if 97% of the scientists if 97% of the
experts in this field believe it then
Who am I to tell them they're wrong all
of us make decisions based on people
that know more about us coming to some
sort of consensus that's how everything
so how could I pretend that that it's
not real just because it makes me feel
better now that doesn't mean that all of
the all of the things that the
government does to make us go green like
Solyndra and some of the other subsidies
that they've done are right because
they're definitely not they're not
necessarily good financially and maybe
not even environmental but we have to we
have to figure out the right way all
right somebody on pay truck so yeah if
you are on patreon if you comment on the
patreon feed we'll give you top priority
over here as you guys know we are fan
funded so it's patreon.com slash rubin
report or rubin report com / donate and
we're building out some interesting
things with the show that we're gonna
let you know in the next week or two so
I'm very excited about that and yeah
we're fully funded meaning by you guys
and you guys know there's issues with
YouTube's monetization right now you
know coming for certain people and all
that kind of stuff so you guys have
allowed me to speak my mind freely and
as I said I think it the last one of
these that we did you know if CNN came
to I got it on over in the background
over here there's Gloria Borger the
woman has never said anything
interesting ever you know even if CNN
came to me tomorrow and said you know
here's three million bucks which
obviously would be a lot more than I'm
making right now you know I love what
I'm doing I love that I can connect
directly to you and build this awesome
team that I have here and do some of the
things that we're about to announce and
all that so so it's very cool you guys
have enabled us to do and I hugely
appreciate it okay why do you think
liberals ignore Bill Clinton's great
accusations it's incredible to me oh man
you know it's such
shame that we have to focus on this but
I think it's a legitimate question and
that's what I was alluding to earlier
that it said that whether whether this
is a hundred whether these allegations
are true or not there are several women
that don't seem like they have much to
gain right now that are in there
probably I would guess they're all in
their 60s or so that don't have much to
gain financially through this that that
something seems to impact seems to I'm
not you know I'm not a mind-reader
like so many people in the news I don't
read minds so unfortunately the left
right now when it comes to this is
completely excusing it because they see
Trump is the number one Eagle so because
of that that's overriding that in this
case you know I talk about the
oppression Olympics all the time their
hatred of Trump is overriding their care
or limiting this in this particular case
so I saw plenty of journalists who I
know and comics who I know and people
who I respect there were all sort of
being extremely dismissive and people on
CNN and everything else extremely
dismissive of these women not to again
Trump was using them for his own tactics
I don't think Trump particularly cares
about these women other than for his own
political means but that seems to be the
world we live in at the moment so so
it's really unfortunate so I I guess I
don't know what we're what we could do
as a country to move forward on this
like if there was some real evidence and
if Hillary actually you know they some
of these women I think Juanita Broderick
specifically accuses Hillary Clinton of
silencing her so if if it happened and
Hillary if there was some evidence you
know some tape or something that was
leaked of Hillary actually trying to
silence or threaten these women are
saying then you have something but for
now you know it's a it's a that stuff
the bus stuff what he said grab him by
the [ __ ] which doesn't work by the way
I went to Starbucks and I tried to grab
some girl by [ __ ] did not work then you
know it's just a sexual it's just a
sideshow so all right there was a yeah
another one for patreon that I'll jump
back into YouTube's heyday do you think
the Supreme Court in appointments would
be the biggest point for the Democrats
it seems like the whole wait for the
election position doesn't have like Ana
Hillary doesn't capitalize it on much
and maybe she ought to so the
interesting thing about the
Supreme Court now look first off we have
an opening right now that the
Republicans have just kicked down the
road which they're not supposed to do
and they are not holding on Obama's
nominee so once again this is this is
partly what ledge the rise of Trump
action a Republican Congress that
refuses to do anything so the Trump
people are pissed at the Republicans too
I think you know the thing with the
Supreme Court is look the Supreme Court
in the last couple years
well first of all we just will talk
about the big one so so abortion i i'm
personally pro-choice i don't like
abortion i wish we could find ways to
help women that are that are pregnant
and don't want to carry the child i wish
we could find ways to do more with
adoption or or some other ways that we
can figure out something so that they
don't have to abort these children and
we have to have an honest conversation
about when does life actually start i
mean if you think it starts the second
that's fun Clegg I'm not a real believer
in that but but by three months they can
probably have some sort of viable thing
and viable life form and that sounds
like an alien but you have some sort of
viable life and that that should be
protected at some level but look all of
these politicians that are against
abortion so when Mike Pence tells you
he's really against abortion I would
suspect that if Mike Pence's daughter
was raped
which obviously horrific and if she was
impregnated well that guess I would
suspect that they would somehow find out
a way for her to get an abortion so and
I think that stands to reason for most
of these guys so I would ultimately let
a woman choose what to do with her own
body but I would acknowledge that they
we are and that's why we have to have an
honest conversation about it so when
people on the right say that the left
liberals hate children or the unborn and
when people on the Left save it that
people on the right hate women it's so
stupid it's so it's incredibly insulting
to our intelligence it's stupid but
below that's an important Supreme Court
question I'm ill of gay marriage was was
made into federal law because of the
Supreme Court because of equal
protection under the law so that's
obviously something that's important to
me and I wouldn't want the Supreme Court
to flip that I
a general rule you know law freedoms
once they get out of it once the thing
is ripped or unless the dam is broke and
the waters pouring it's hard to get that
back into the cup so I don't think that
we would take away freedoms but there is
a risk I think of changing the the
makeup of the Supreme Court that I mean
that would be somewhat risky I think
with Donald Trump because now suddenly
he's hedging again on the gay marriage
thing although I don't see that I don't
see how that would get up to the Supreme
Court again but he's old but his
abortion stance which I mean he's a New
York guy and lord knows what he's done
in his life so the idea that he would be
against abortion which I'm not sure he's
not really making a big issue but it
sounds like he's kind of pandering for
that again you know the thing about
Trump is I think he's just pandering to
everybody so I don't think he believes
any of this stuff that he said to most
people so maybe there's some maybe
there's a silver lining in that somehow
somebody said do you ever think a rise
of the libertarian right will ever
dominate the Republican Party whoa whoa
this is my biggest disappointment
believe it or not Trump and Clinton or
not my biggest disappointment in this in
this election cycle by the way note my
roads farms cozy from my favorite farm
in Missouri check it out so my biggest
disappointment in this election actually
is in Trump or Clinton which obviously
are both disappointing my biggest
disappointment is that the libertarians
had a chance and that's why a few months
ago you guys saw that I did that video
about Karen Johnson how I wanted him to
get to 15% and let's see some
libertarian ideals they're about lower
taxes and limited government and strong
military so that you don't have to use
it and not caring about gay marriage and
not caring about marijuana why would you
ever what rights the government has to
tell you you have cancer you amaze you
have some are considers I am what rights
the government has to tell you if
something is gonna help you survive help
you deal with your pain and you're gonna
let the government tell you what to do
[ __ ] and guess what all again it's
like the abortion thing before every
single one of these politicians would do
anything that they could do if they were
in pain or their children are in pain so
don't let them tell you that you can't
smoke weed if it's gonna help you any
guess wait forget even medicinal
marijuana if you want to smoke weed
chill upon this IKEA couch maybe I've
done it once or twice that guess what
that's okay too
so the disappointment with Garry Johnson
is that I wanted him in there just so
people could hear some libertarian ideas
some classic liberal and libertarian
ideas let's base policy on rationality
and logic and reason and all that good
stuff
and unfortunately Garry Johnson and I
said this in my initial thing he's not a
great candidate he's not particularly
well-spoken he fumbles over himself a
lot and sounds like a cartoon character
he's not a great libertarian he was for
forcing the Baker in Indiana to fake the
gay marriage shake him and this is just
silly for a libertarian let the market
decide
guess what go to a different Baker use
your dollar to vote right so and then
there are a couple of and then the
electrical thing in a bunch of a bunch
of other gas that he's had so I wish the
libertarian that had a better standard
bearer for their message I think that
the best move that could have happened
to them would have been that Rand Paul
would have said you know what I've had
it with the Republicans I see the
writing on the wall I was one of the
seventeen at the beginning of this thing
with Trump but I didn't even have a
chance so let me be the libertarian but
you know what he wants to stay a senator
and if he's gonna stay a senator but he
has to stay a Republican so everyone
covers their own ass that's just the way
it is but I think that was the
disappointment for me about the
libertarians or or that a classic that a
real classic liberal party would would
evolve out of a Democratic Party I think
that would be nice too but I do think
what's happening here is look we're
watching the Republican Party completely
split right the republican party is now
splitting into the trumps the
conservatives and then and then the
libertarians on the far side of it not
far right as much as just sort of the
fringe part of it but the Trump people
and the classical people that I thought
of as the conservative party those these
are two parties right now they're not
the same party and you could just look
at all the people all the Senators
Republican senators and congressmen who
dropped Trump yesterday that's just
proof of it on the Left I sense this
crumbling - there was a huge difference
right now think about all these
progressives
think of all the progressives you know
that we're all Pro Bernie right and
wanted money out of Wall Street money
out of politics and they didn't want
drone strikes and they were against the
wars about they're all back in Hillary
so where are their principal
so I would say those are really two
parties right now the progressives and
the sort of mainstream Democrat so I
would love to see a couple more parties
here as I've said repeatedly there is
nothing in our Constitution that says
we're only supposed to have a two
parties they've tricked us into thinking
that we're supposed to have some sort of
duopoly here and there's a reason that
they both get a shitload of money from
everything so the most important thing
you can do I think he stopped giving
them money
stop giving politicians money period you
can do something better with your money
I'm sure you can find something in case
you guys didn't catch that did Trump
pacing affect anything in concurrence
people claim about intimidation there
was something weird look he's a lot
bigger than her he's six foot something
she's she's smaller obviously so there
was something a little weird about the
walking around it never got to that
point you know there's that great moment
with Al Gore and George W Bush and how I
just kept walking to and that Bush just
like looks in my way they've never got
that weird but just because of the
difference in physicality and a little
bit of the man-woman thing it's just a
reality whatever that was you know so
because of some of that I think that it
could have appeared to be a little
intimidating but you know it's not like
he was gonna hit her or something so it
is what it is I think that's just more
on theater um Dave gyro he's very
negative about Hillary Rodham Clinton is
there something you'd like is there
something you like about her would she
be a good president look look I don't
really like her I just don't and I don't
really like Trump either but my sense is
that if you just want more of the same
like we're all I think because of the
internet so many people are waking up to
how screwed up our system is how our
media is in bed with the politicians
house Hillary was in bed with the DNC to
get rid of Bernie how she's been for the
Iraq war she is for Libya what it look
look what's happening in Syria she was
for all these things so I do think Trump
scores points when he says you know a
lot of she's like it's just words he's
like it's just words she's like go to my
website see what I say yeah it's just
words so I think if you if you just
think everything's going okay and and
you don't want that much change and
you're okay with a lot of the trends
that we have you know the things that I
that I see is very dangerous with social
justice and trigger warnings and you
know and dividing people based on
everything then I think you can vote
with her in good conscience
I'm truly I'm not sure what I'm gonna do
but I can I can see legitimate reasons
despite everything really
I can see legitimate reasons to vote for
both of them if you know the immigration
thing right if you asked you know
there's this idea that because our
borders or something or if we vent in a
certain way that this is based on racism
this is just silly
we know for a fact Isis tells us this
but our own CIA tells listen this to an
FBI but they want to send fighters in
here we know that these that attacks all
over the world whether it's in Paris or
Belgium or in Holland or right here if
it's in San Bernardino or in Orlando or
whatever we know that there are people
that want to come in here and these lone
wolves and and sometimes bigger cells
and we know that they want to kill us
that is a different situation than we've
had in with immigration in the past do
we trust our vetting system i I don't I
don't know I don't even know nobody even
really tells us about it
by the way most of these people they are
vetted or they're on watch lists the
birthday lando guy who is on a watch
list bernardino guys were on watch lists
so we have to deal with real problems
so because we don't deal with real
problems then someone like Trump comes
in and says I'm gonna build a wall and
everyone says well we better do a wall
because we're not gonna the other way I
think there is a medium in there but my
point is that you know if the people in
Europe fight if you could say that could
you guys like you guys in Germany you
guys in Belgium you guys France and
Greece and a bunch of the other
countries Holland if you guys could roll
it back five years and not allow the
immigration to get to the levels it got
to now you have all these problems with
rapes and people fighting on the street
and they have financial burdens and all
this stuff would you do it differently
I'm pretty sure
most of them would say yes it's a lot to
do with why it breaks it happen so we
have to have an honest debate about it
before we make a decision but clearly
we're not in a place to have a real good
honest discussion about anything but I
somehow that started with the question
about do I like Hillary came to that so
I wish I just trusted her I don't know
what look I voted Democrat in my life
for every election when people could say
they've not a liberal anymore tonight
I voted Democrat for every single day I
voted for Obama twice every local thing
I think the only time if I'm not
mistaken the only time I can remember
not voting Democrat was for Giuliani's
third term after 9/11 I keep both Korean
or that was it right before that I'm
blanking but right around there I could
both for Giuliani once and he was a
former Democrat by the way so the
Democratic Party was a little more
flexible mentally and not just doing so
much shady [ __ ] I really do and that in
no way is an endorsement of the right
it's just what it is okay let's see this
is wrong yes the deal with Paul Ryan
heating everything that Trump does but
still supports him shows me not more
else so what is the deal with Paul Ryan
hating everything Trump does but still
supporting him so this is playing
politics to the worst kind of thing if
you're Paul Ryan Paul Ryan is a big iron
gram guy he's really a libertarian at
heart he wants really limited government
he wants low taxes he doesn't I don't
think he sees eye-to-eye with Trump on
anything anything but he's the head of
the party room he's the head of the
party basically Trump is the nominee and
they're they're trying to you know come
to some de x so that they can move
forward together
I think he's hedging his bets all of
these people are hedging their bets I
think all of these people yesterday that
dropped out McCain and all that whole
crew of Republicans that that dropped
out yesterday did they suddenly did
these words suddenly make them say they
can't support Trump or do they suddenly
see a floodgate and I thought man I
gotta get off jump off [ __ ] now before
this thinks
now ironically because Trump survived
tonight and did okay I haven't seen what
everyone's saying already I'm only going
up my own brain so far but because of
that you know some of them may look
Syrian if Trump wins you know oh well
that Trump is going to make sure that
there's hell to pay
why don't you write a libertarian a lot
of people on your screen why do I think
Paul Ryan's a libertine I mean I know he
loves Iran and he talks about at the
shrug and Fountainhead and some other
stuff am I mistaken on that I think he'd
most well I don't think he's he's not a
libertarian that say I'm a libertarian
but I think he has a lot of libertarian
principles in him oh I can do a lot more
research on that we got that one already
liberals in the rape accusations why
they were so Hillary in the war with
Russia look it's pretty obvious that
there's something weird I shot my a
direct message we were for this week's
show a shot at last week of Cathy young
man who's wonderful writer and she gets
[ __ ] from the people the regressive left
and the all right I think you guys are
really digging and she was born in
Russia lived there till she was 16 and
my direct message that I shot which is
from a couple days ago I talked about
how it seems obvious to me that over the
next month we're gonna hear more and
more and more about Russia and that the
Democrats he will play to the Democrats
advantage to become more hawkish on
Russia because they want to pin it that
somehow the WikiLeaks because WikiLeaks
is damaging Hillary by releasing her
emails and showing the shady [ __ ] she
was doing with Wall Street and and a
bunch of and you know more with emails
and connections and Clinton Foundation
all that that the Democrats are becoming
more hawkish on on Russia what's also
interesting is that a lot of the
nevertrump people were the neo cons and
you can sense that some of them are
gonna vote for Hillary stead of Trump
so it is um I don't think we're gonna be
able as I say in the direct message
you'll see it on Wednesday I don't think
this means we're gonna be in another
cold war with Russia necessarily or
certainly not hot war but we are sort of
fighting
see were with them right now in Syria
and the question is you know who who
benefits from the hostilities and right
now the Democrats been from benefit from
hostilities with them and when you know
the fact that you know Hillary was into
the Iraq war she was into the Libya war
and some other stuff and has been okay
with whatever it is that they're doing
Syria which nobody seems to know and
there's 400,000 people dead in the last
couple years you know it seems that the
Bennett the Democrats benefit from it
more than the Republicans do at the
moment all right what else we got here
so there were a couple other a couple
other moments that I thought were that I
thought were good you know the question
from the from the Muslim girl and
talking about immigration and I sort of
addressed that already but this isn't
this is an important piece and what
Trump said is we want extreme Bennet so
it's really about what do you believe
the government is gonna do do you want
to just let people and do you trust that
we're gonna vet properly I don't know I
do you I'm curious what do you guys
think I I don't know that we can trust
that the government knows what they're
doing right now they certainly didn't do
it well in Europe by the way also
WikiLeaks released an email from Hillary
this week saying that she wanted open
borders so we have these are these are
real things you know they're showing on
CNN right now when they both walked out
and it looked like maybe there was gonna
be a handshake but then there was and I
did but I didn't see if there was a
handshake at the end if someone could
let me know in the comment section if
there was one okay let's see what do you
think about the last question about
something nice about each other you know
stuff like that it's just silly stupid
stuff at the end Hillary's answer your
kids are good
I mean her kids relentlessly expect
especially Donald Trump jr. relentlessly
attacks Hillary I think Eric Trump does
it pretty significant too Ivanka has
been a little bit above the fray in that
regard but you know it's a pretty safe
answer you know what do you what do you
think about it kid yeah but you know the
kid the kids are okay so I thought that
was fine and I thought Trump's answer on
that was she doesn't give up basically
and that she fights
I think he actually probably does
respect her for that as much as he
disagrees with everything about her and
all that kind of stuff but he probably
does agree with that there was a
handshake at the end so there was a
handshake at the end so that's good I
guess
I guess that's good let's see what are
they giving me here I got a lot of stuff
here movie things fast hey singing a
trunk we did that scroll down how do you
think Washington Hancock and who and
Franklin would feel about the election
etcetera the election or the debates or
whatever I think they would be
incredibly disappointed like this is
such horseshit have real debates that
talk really about liberty talk about the
rights of the individual to the right to
pursue happiness talk about why not I'm
gonna do this with I was the one that
sorry the thing into this to spend this
much money to do this so I did this and
I'll do this know a good government is
one that you don't have to talk about a
lot I tweeted something before that got
a lot of that got a lot of reach me
talking about that a good government
what was my to tweet about taxes it was
something like your government should
spend less of your money not someone
give it to me i cup coating myself my
gun and very poorly here but but that's
what government a good government he
wouldn't talk about it that much this I
don't think that Clinton and Trump are
the examples of a healthy government oh
here's what I said I said we should all
be for lower taxes the government should
waste less not take more I mean we
should be talking about whether you
agree with me or not whether you
disagree with me if you're a progressive
and in here and you want to tax rich
people with 75% then you completely
disagree with what I wrote then we
should be talking about that and we
shouldn't be arguing about that that
would be completely fine with me but
we're not really talking about the idea
is we're talking about a little
nonsensical nonsensical things and also
you know the bigger problem is that the
debaters you know I've said this a bunch
of times but the debaters the moderator
sorry the moderator is
jump every time there's a there's a you
talk over someone sorry
you went too long sup know let them
battle let them battle and let's see
what happens that's what we need to do
by the way for all the people that are
like depressed about this or think how
horrible this is or all this I would say
this you know so many people are engaged
right now maybe for all the wrong
reasons maybe because it's a [ __ ] show
maybe because of the [ __ ] and this and
that and all that other stuff but you
know what people are engaged and the
thing is if we would have had more
people engaged Phil last 20 years we
wouldn't have got to this point so the
key is that no matter what happens after
November 8th that we stay engaged that's
the most important thing is that you got
to stay engaged and if you're if you
whether Trump wins or Hillary wins if
you're sick of this if you had it with
these people and this way of this this
[ __ ] that the media gives you I'm
watching Wolf Blitzer right now the guy
couldn't improv his way out of a wet
paper bag if you're sick of these
generic people just spouting [ __ ] to
you then stay engaged make a youtube
show you know put stuff on Facebook
fight for some truth to get out there
because the media is not gonna give it
to us so that's so in a way that's my
biggest fear with Hillary's that the
entire machine that we all see such
garbage now why would why would she
change the machine because the Machine
wants her to win obviously Trump would
have more of an incentive to try to
change the machine but by that token you
know Trump at the same all these people
later say Trump will be politically
incorrect then he'll save free speech
and all that this is the guy that
threatens to sue reporters so we don't
have great options here we don't yeah I
know that's gonna upset everybody from
patreon being outside the US Australia
the presidential race between these two
deeply flawed candidates gives you the
impression that US democracy is very
broken is this the feeling within the
United States in it so where will change
come from I think a lot of people feel
like it's like it's broken you know it's
it's funny like I say this all the time
now we have so much good going on here
in this country we but most people in
this country wake up and try to get to a
job and get some food hopefully you have
some sex whatever that's it you know you
get to live your life
and you have your free thoughts and you
can fiddle around on social media you
can play video games play sports
whatever it is we don't have massive
wars on our territory we don't we don't
even a massive terrorism on our
territory we don't have you know there's
so many things that are bad in other
places where they don't have running
water and they don't and they have much
bigger well income disparagement than we
had even though ours is big there's so
much good here there and there by the
way there is also so much tolerance you
know the media is only gonna show you
things when we hate each other and
they'll trick you into thinking that
when a black cop shoots a black person
that that somehow is about racism too
because they want us all to hate each
other because the more that we hate each
other the more they will click on their
garbage the more that will watch their
nonsense and the more that they can
control us eventually I don't want to
control any of you I want you to think
for yourselves and if you don't want to
watch this anymore you wanted like
something else go ahead good for you but
stay here but the point is that it's
pretty good here and if you if you don't
know that it's pretty good I would say
that anyone whether you're in the United
States or you're in Australia come to
New York City and ride around the New
York City subway and you will find every
person of every color and religion and
creed and ethnicity and sexuality and
everything else there is and we're all
on there together and guess what nobody
looks happy nobody really wants to be
there but we're there and we're in peace
and we're functioning together and
that's the sign of a good society and we
have to we have to honor that and know
that that for our it's all screwy it
feels really screwy but it's still
pretty good here and I wouldn't want to
throw the baby out with the bathwater
and that's what I think we'd have to
have to watch out for it let's see do
you think that we need some philosophers
in charge after all this garbage the
president that educates the people would
be nice yeah that's a really interesting
idea you know I wouldn't say that you
know in a lot of European countries they
have a friend Ava King someone McCain
still or they have a president and a
prime minister meaning that there's a
ceremonial thing so the king or the
queen is ceremonial really he doesn't
have much real decision-making power and
then you've got in most cases it's the
president of these countries that also
is ceremonial and then the Prime
Minister is the one that's in effect
that's our president right so I think we
could have sound like that
is that we're trying to make we're
trying to make kings and queens with
Trump and Clinton they're only a third
of the government we have three branches
of government they're the executive
branch but that's only supposed to sign
things into law the the legislative
branch is supposed to write the laws the
judicial branch is supposed to make sure
they're legal they're a third of the
government but we spend all of our time
worrying about the this third so watch I
got the CNN panel there they got 87
people let's look at this guy they work
for Trump work for Clinton works for
Trump works for Clinton works for
Clinton used to work for Obama it's such
garbage it's garbage know that that's
garbage know that that's garbage despite
the fact I'm not saying every single
person on there is garbage because
there's a couple people that I think are
decent I think Jake Tapper really does
try the best he can knowing that he's
surrounded by a lot of garbage and you
can tell it see the look is in his eye
the entire time what are we laughing oh
there's a giant picture that's a letter
is a giant Wolf Blitzer head on a stick
that's most animated that Wolf Blitzer
has ever been his head on a stick flying
yeah we got to find the funny in some of
this we got to not hate each other over
this nuts nonsense you know like that
that's the stuff but but don't watch
these channels and think that they're
gonna tell you anything that's
insightful or honest every single one of
these Pursy people maybe the David
Axelrod who works video mama campaign is
gonna tell you that Trump might owe on
that debate do you think that the
Jeffrey Lord who's a trump surrogate is
gonna tell you Oh Hillary mighta won
it's all garbage they're wasting your
time and your brain cells by by spending
any time up that's why this is cool
because there are real people out there
that want actually some real truth it's
not it's not that hard I don't think I'm
doing rocket science I'm just telling
you what I think all right let's see
what else is going on your show so the
idea of having philosophers in charge
the problem is that we've created this
cult of personality to the point where
what's good about having a queen like a
ceremonial thing or a president and a
prime ministers to to make as two
different things is that you can get
some of the pomp and circumstances Larry
there's Wolf's giant head right behind
Gloria Borger
you can get you can get some of the pomp
and circumstance I was
and then and then the Prime Minister or
whoever's actually supposed to lead the
government can be the actual leader
right and do the leading so to your
question about philosophers I would love
that if we had like some council not
that they can make decisions per se but
that they could guide the decisions you
know if you didn't see our show last
week we had Zoltan Istvan running as the
transhumanist candidate for president
obviously very few people know about him
he's not going to get 1% of the vote but
his whole point is that there are so
many future technologies between AI and
gene-splicing and being able to pick the
traits of your children and chips medial
implants and yourself to open doors and
do all kinds of stuff and genome and all
that that we have so many huge huge
issues coming down the pipe that are
just gonna start coming faster and
faster and faster because technology is
getting faster and faster and faster and
because of that we better start
addressing some of this stuff now you
should better start having honest
conversations about this stuff now the
ethics behind it and what if the robots
take over and all kinds of stuff so if
we had a panel of philosophers or
scientists or whatever that just were
they don't have to be official in any
capacity that they're writing laws but
that would be advising the people
writing laws in a really honest
functional way I think that would be I
think that would be pretty great I don't
know that that's gonna happen so did NBC
released the tape way ahead there's a
way to create do I think Trump released
the tape so that it would get out now
instead of a week before the election I
don't know that he would have access to
the NBC tape so I think that would be a
bit of a conspiracy theory right there
the question is what more is there
because there probably is more and so
that's so that's huge
is is there more and the but also as I
said before words and actions are two
different things I'm not excusing what
he said do I want someone with you know
it's just a shitty situation it's just
all right leader vers manager these are
important concepts what do you think
Trump is what do you think Clinton is
what is our country that's interesting
leader reverse manager so Trump I think
would probably be you know what it's
hard to say here's what I would say
Trump I think we would be a manager and
that he would delegate work I don't know
that he really likes to work I think he
likes to talk I think he likes to sit on
his golden chair I think he likes to
spray tan and you know has probably his
gallop from all the rich foods he's
eating but I don't know that he wants to
actually work there were rumors that he
at one point said to John Kasich I think
be my VP you can pretty much do the job
because he likes the ceremonial part of
it he likes ego part of it so I think in
a certainly he would be more of a
manager he would manage the people but
but at the same time he kind of it like
being the supreme leader I think we all
know that as for Hillary it from
everything I've heard about her she
really does like getting input from
people and she's an extremely good
delegator and you know he's able to
manage people in a proper way to make
things happen and whether those
decisions are good or not we don't know
and by the way for people that think I
gave Hilary more [ __ ] in in that regard
she is a longer record of shading them
one of the benefits you get when you
haven't been in politics is that there
isn't a record of your decisions related
to political issues to not so you know
look Obama didn't have a great record
before it's funny like when Obama was
running eight years ago people were like
he's young he's French whatever and
that's what all the Liberals are saying
and now it's like now they got like the
40-year stodgy been a senator been a
first lady been a Secretary of State
bubble box and it's like experience
matters
everybody just changes and picks their
side whatever whatever they want you
from patreon what do you think about
Julian Assange trolling everyone by
saying he has a big leak at 3:00 a.m.
and I'm just doing a fundraiser what's
going on with WikiLeaks do they have
something that can take down Clinton so
here's the thing I'm basically for look
we might have state secrets that could
be of such tantamount or such
huge importance that it would not be
good if the average person knew that's
just a sad reality so the idea that
governments can be completely every
level whatsoever it's just that's just a
utopian paradise that doesn't exist that
say our government should not be spying
on us and our government should be more
open Obama said he was gonna have the
most transparent government in
administration in history I mean you'd
have to be an idiot I think that's true
so the problem with the challenge is
that he obviously has a political
motivation here because he leaks things
out he obviously doesn't like Hillary he
and that's why Hillary is trying to pin
Assange she's trying to make it sound
like the Russians have something to do
with the Sun and that's why they're
there working together or working with
Trump to stop her she got to show great
evidence of that to make it seem
actually true so I don't know look I
don't know what his motivation is but it
seems pretty clear to me that he's gonna
keep dropping [ __ ] and the biggest risk
the biggest risk that we have to worry
about right now with both of these
candidates because they're both so
flawed but I think this one goes more to
Hillary because she has a record in
government is that they could have
information on her that not only could
they wait till the day before the
election to throw it up in flux but they
could drop it the day after the election
and that could be massively destructive
at many levels with Trump it's like if
there's there might be more than he said
more horrible things and disgusting
things about women or about minorities
or whatever that would not be good but
it wouldn't it wouldn't be like a
national security risk but there is a
potential that they have something on
Hillary but again that's a that's a
conjecture right there so I don't know I
don't know what WikiLeaks is motivation
it's what you have they have you can't
just pretend they're just doing this for
the good of transparency now they're
obviously up some sort of political
motivation let's see what do you think
about Trump breaking with pens on Syria
and what this means for the Trump Penn's
presidency of Trump wins so it's funny
right after that I immediately tweeted I
was just trying to tweet like some some
old thing it just hit me it was like you
know Trump because he's a showman and I
watched the celebrity
it's believed that he could suddenly be
like you know what pence you're gone
either way you didn't really back me
these last two days you've dropped out
of an event you're gone I'm gonna fire
you you're fine and then because of that
yeah so because of that show me that
again just a second okay thanks so I
thought maybe that would be the move you
just drop him out of nowhere you get the
race back in flux everyone stops talking
about [ __ ] you're good to go
apparently mike pence tweeted right
after the debate Congrats to my running
mate real Donald Trump on a big win
proud to stand with you as we Mak make
America great again
so I suspect I was probably wrong on
that the question that was about Trump
and pence on Syria look in a lot of ways
pence is more if you if you're a liberal
if you're as moderate you're you're a
Democrat that might vote for Trump even
if you're a sort of mainstream
conservative but not a Christian
conservative or a far-right conservative
pace is much more of a risk I think than
Trump is in a lot of ways because he
comes from that Christian Right his
abortion stuff was terrible
his gay right stuff is terrible I think
that that would be a huge a huge huge
problem as for the serious stuff I think
that they would come to some agreement
on that
my personal belief on the Syria thing is
that Obama
what did make a bad mistake Obama said I
have a red line they crossed the red
line Obama did nothing our allies then
go Weymouth wait a minute is this how
things behave and then our allies start
wondering about us and then our enemies
are involved so I would have not wanted
you see that you can find video of me
during that time completely against any
military action in Syria when I was on
to you idea at the time I was completely
against it several of the hosts were
foreign that was completely against it
and you can also find that I was
completely against the military the
kinetic military action that Hillary is
for in Libya which led to Benghazi and
now the funny thing is funny of the sad
thing is does anyone know what's going
on in in Libya right now is it a
functioning state we don't even talk
about it but we toppled Qaddafi who is
obviously a bad person but so in Syria I
would be for creating some sort of
Manit Aryan corridor there where it's
just transferring people into some
safety something the problem is we don't
know it's very hard to tell what side
were on and it's very hard to tell who
our allies are and you know what also
why can't other countries in the area do
something why of all the Gulf countries
close the door to their Muslim brothers
why is an old man in United Arab
Emirates and Qatar these rich rich ulema
wants in on this these rich rich
countries why haven't they done anything
about this she's very passionate about
refugees actually she's a rescue from
Hurricane Katrina so no way she is she's
a refugee from New Orleans I suppose why
don't these countries do anything about
it they don't so it's one of those
things where it's like if we do
something then then people hate us and
if we don't do something then people die
so it's a shitty situation now it's
definite
all right you know what we're gonna do
you know what I'm gonna do 20 minutes
for a patreon only bonus for for 20
minutes after this so we're gonna wrap
this thing up in ten minutes and then
I'm gonna go live for patrons only
for like 20 minutes or a half hour so to
remind you guys we're a fully fan funded
show I left the networks that are that
we created a production company I am the
head of a production company we got pay
insurance payroll and a whole bunch of
other [ __ ] I don't think I'm gonna be
able to write off the 99.5 9 91 950
million dollars that Trump pulled off
but yeah we are we are fan funded
through you guys and you've helped us
build the show we've got a couple big
announcements in the next couple weeks
and I'm very excited about that we're
gonna sort of be changing how we do some
things and expanding on a couple things
it's very cool so you go to
patreon.com/scishow or tom says donate
but I will finish up here if any strong
so anyway so look at the end of the day
when you watch all this stuff as I now
watch Paul Begala on CNN and guess what
all the galas the head but he's an
adviser to a Hillary super PAC I wonder
you think Hillary he might be saying
Hillary won what do you think he might
just be I think so
so these [ __ ] artists
so about the web loss thing as I said
earlier Trump just had to surprise to
survive he just had to get through
tonight because the wheels were really
coming off this thing by the way you
know when you talk about just how the
media frames everything and how rough
that becomes and how dishonest it
becomes look what he said it was worthy
of news of course but if you watched all
I watched today I did an hour and a half
a cardio this morning and I watched I
flipped through all the channels the
entire time virtually non-stop about
Trump in the bus comments and pretty
much nothing on Hillary and the
WikiLeaks stuff telling Wall Street that
they could regulate themselves in effect
and and the stuff about open borders in
a budget so it's like you have to be
honest yes talking about open borders
isn't as juicy as [ __ ] but you have to
be honest and we have to have a media
that will touch both of these things
that's not a particularly whatever but
yeah you have to you have to call out
both sides we need a media to do that we
need a fourth state to do that and
unfortunately that's being levied on
online people you know and it's it's a
big job but somebody's got to do it and
with great power comes great
responsibility all right you know what
I'll take I'll take two more questions
here so if you guys want to fire off two
more in the in the youtube comment
section I'll take two more right now and
then and then we're gonna move over to
patreon patreon.com slash Rubin report
so we have one more of these things and
that's gonna be interesting because now
it's like look that's it all you have to
do is survive that's what he did now you
get one more and here we go all right
let's see do you think it would be
better for Trump to win because the
Republicans are more likely to
potentially impeach him then the Dems
with Hillary do you see reform more
likely under Trump or Hillary you know
that's interesting because the funny
thing is that I think whichever one of
these people win I'm pretty sure
there'll be a one-term president because
now we're so sick in the system no
matter what that I don't think the
person would have the votes to stick
around the second time would be my
suspicion but you know anything could
happen to be it some war that causes you
know wartime incumbent president so we
stay in
I would I don't know about impeachment
of course right like you'd have to catch
that really catch them insane but yeah
if the main look if the mainstream the
Trump wins the republican-controlled
Congress most likely they're not going
to impeach him because they're gonna go
out we're back in like we're dealt
backing our guys in and even if we
didn't like Trump we like a winner so I
think it would be more more of a chance
that they would try to impeach Hillary
but in terms of reform who I think would
make more reform in government I suspect
that would be Trump now that doesn't
mean it would be good but I pick them
these two people where he's been around
and in power forever so you know and in
the halls of power forever if not
directly making the decision so would
she change and I know she's benefited a
lot from it now look that's the irony of
Trump too is that for all the stuff that
he complained about he's benefited from
the system
great now some people that like him say
that's his greatest strength that he's
going he's going wow I've benefited from
the system but I see that it's crappy
for other people so I help them I don't
know if he's that altruistic really but
in terms of who would really change the
system more I think it's pretty obvious
that it would be Trump again whether
that change would be good or not is that
would remain to be seen
okay so last one and then we're going to
jump over to or do two more real quick
than jump over to patron so do you think
Trump will be more the more serious
allegations will be leveled at Trump
soon yeah my guess is yeah I I don't
first off you know NBC news when they
drop that tape how long did they know
about that tape did they drop it just
because the WikiLeaks stuff came out
about Hillary that same day I mean I
suspect there will be more coming out
about Trump I heard some rumors today on
Twitter which I'm not going to repeat
here because repeat rumors but I suspect
there is more this guy has been on
camera for a long time he's a loose
cannon that talks and speaks his mind
and I would suspect that you're gonna
find many more hot mic moments with him
and as I said before about the hot mic
stuff you know what all of these people
that are that are like you forget forget
public people all of you that are that
are listening to this that are watching
this I think everybody here has says
things privately to their spouse or to
their
your cousin or whatever privately in
their own home that they don't say
publicly doesn't mean you're saying
gross and racist stuff but but you say
things differently you make jokes
differently whatever it is and you're
entitled to do that the privacy of your
own home so I would be leery of just
nailing everyone on these mic moments
but I have a feeling yes there is gonna
be more of it and finally what does it
say that gay marriage marijuana reform
etc haven't been discussed look at the
gay marriage thing well I'm glad it's
not discussed cuz it's here it's here
and it's the only way it could go away
at this point is if a case got all the
way back up to the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court had flipped so
significantly which I suppose could
happen if Trump was to put in people
that he says he might put in but back
then it would be flipped I suspect that
that's not gonna happen
as for as for marijuana legal marijuana
you know it absolutely should be legal
as I said before just on the medicinal
side forget what you think about
marijuana the drug if you had any sort
of disease what right I if you were in
pain picture you wouldn't paint right
now you look shoulder pain I'm not even
talking about cancers I'm gonna be a bad
shoulder well you don't want to take
Advil you don't take whatever you like
how it affects your liver you don't
wanna take you see the Minutemen okay
and you can take a puff the weed and
your shoulder pain will go away guess
what it would be okay I know people that
have had cancer that had cancer right
now that smoked meat that people are
people with Parkinson's and epilepsy and
AIDS and all of these things what right
do you have as a human being
forget the government what right do you
have to tell someone else how they
should be able to deal with their own
pain and as I said before even removing
the pain part from this you know what
I'm having a beer right now
fear is a drug appear is people becoming
addicted and died of alcoholism they
drive into and kill people in cars all
kinds of things nobody is killing anyone
because of marijuana I have a marijuana
license here in LA and what I eat when I
don't even smoke that off and honestly I
spoke maybe maybe maybe twice a week and
I take one freaking pump and I'm good to
go and I watch repeats of the Simpsons
and what what right does the government
have to say no you can't do that so
that's why we talk about
over them so anyway that that's about it
I hope you guys enjoyed this and I'm
glad that people are engaged more than
anything else stay engaged and keep
talking about what you think is right
and don't be afraid to share your
opinions and share things on Facebook
and say things on Twitter and be watch
the mainstream media with the curious
eye and and a questioning attitude and
and that's it so I'm gonna jump onto
patreon so you guys can jump on there
now it's patreon.com slash rubin report
or fully fan funded we appreciate what
you guys are doing for us and we'll do
will do something live over there for a
little bit and that's it we got one more
of these and then one parent apparently
we have an election although I would be
for a meteor strike before then all
right Joe
[Music]